we have new developments in a bizarre
attempted murder case that we first told
you about last year a young man Jake
Nolan claims he was brainwashed by his
psychiatrist so he could kill on her
behalf he is serving time in prison now
five years after the attack the woman he
claims was the mastermind dr. Pamela
bookbinder is under arrest
48 hours correspondent Peter Franzen has
a preview of tomorrow night's report on
this case
Jake Nolan readily admits he walked into
a New York City high-rise on November 12
2012 with murder on his mind I planned
on killing Michael Weiss dr. Michael
Weiss is a psychiatrist inside Jake's
duffle bag a knife and a large
sledgehammer he sees the sledgehammer
and charges at me and I reached for the
knife Jake's attorney Rogers Davis this
is not a whodunit he did what he was
accused of doing but the big question
was why I saw Jake Nolan brainwashed by
dr. Pamela Buchbinder dr. bookbinder is
another psychiatrist and Jake's cousin
she and dr. Weiss were battling over
custody of their son they hated each
other
and in turn she made me hate him Jay
claims dr. bookbinder manipulated him to
kill by filling his head with horror
stories about her ex and he says he was
vulnerable because he suffers from
bipolar and other disorders and she
morphed me into whatever she wanted me
to be this surveillance footage shows
dr. bookbinder with Jake paying for that
sledgehammer the night before the attack
and after stabbing dr. Weiss and being
wounded in the struggle Jake picked up
his cell phone took this bloody selfie
and sent it to her what is going through
your mind
when you took this picture that I let
down Pamela in March of 2016
three and a half years after the attack
Jake was found guilty of attempted
murder and was sentenced to nine and a
half years in prison I know what I did
was very serious but there is also
another party that needs to take
responsibility too and that person is
Pamela bookbinder
Pamela bookbinder Peter Vansant from 48
hours I have a simple question why did
you buy that sledgehammer on October
19th almost five years after Michael
Wiese was attacked the law finally
caught up with this Ivy League
psychiatrist
Eric Franz one of dr. bookbinders
lawyers says Jake acted alone
Pamela Buchbinder is an educated
psychiatrist not Wiley coyote dr. Pamela
bookbinder remains in Rikers Island jail
and Peter Van Zant is here with us good
morning good morning so what is this new
evidence that led to the arrest of book
minder five years after it wasn't new
evidence it was just it came up to the
statute of limitations and they finally
decided let's give this a shot so that
was quite a question that you asked why
did you buy that sledgehammer I was very
curious to hear her answer what will be
your defense at trial this time do you
think at trial her attorneys said well
you got to stay tuned we won't tell you
yet but they can explain the
sledgehammer and they also hope to
introduce a new piece of evidence
allegedly a handwritten note from Jake
Nolan that boy who's mentally ill that
says Pamela had nothing to do with this
will she make bail she's been turned
down twice for bail cuz when she was
arrested she had her passport her birth
certificate her child's passport and she
was staying at a friend's house in
upstate New York so prosecutors believe
because she has some wealth that she is
a flight risk
again I'm intrigued very good all
intrigued
Peter thank you very much you can watch
Peters full report the psychiatrist and
the Selphy on 48 hours that is tomorrow
night at 10:00 9:00 central right here
on CBS